[Musique]
handy je sais que ce déménagement a été
très dur mais c'était censé être un
nouveau départ pour nous tu avais dit
essaierez de te faire de nouveaux
copains fortis connect et contrôler tous
vos produits qu'haslam et tous les
appareils connectés de la maison
nous vous présentons votre nouveau
meilleur ami
[Musique]
g
et
maman il faut que je te dise un truc et
j'ai vraiment besoin tu crois je pense
que dieu qui a fait recours
andy si tu sais quoi que ce soit vaut
mieux que tu me le disent bien tout qui
va pas chez ceux qui se connectent est
content ce qui est un jouet il peut être
n'importe où bienvenue chez kstr cars
[Musique]
oh
et
il faut qu'on arrête
oh
jamais
boney m